nous restons dans le Val-de-Marne avec
la question numéro 73 de Madame
Catherine procacia à monsieur le
ministre chargé des transports de la mer
et de la pêche
merci de répondre pour le ministre des
Transports en tout cas j'espère avoir
une réponse puisque ça fait plus de 2
ans que j'interviens régulièrement au
nom des élus de du Val-de-Marne mais
aussi au nom des usagers et que nous
n'obtenons jamais de réponse
précise quel que soit les ministres des
Transports successifs donc j'espère que
le changement c'est aujourd'hui pour
avoir une réponse
sur dans le Val-de-Marne nous avons
l'autoroute A4 à 86 qui est un tronçon
commun qui accueille tous les jours 280
000 automobilistes dont 26
25000 poids lourds qui arrivent non
seulement de toute la France mais aussi
de toute l'Europe du Nord et de l'Est et
c'est l'un des points noirs si ce n'est
le point noir de la circulation le plus
célèbre malheureusement en Île-de-France
et en France nos collègues de province
connaissent la cata 86 presque tous les
jours y compris en province on entend
parler de ces fameux bouchons donc il y
a quelques années une idée originale
avait eu lieu en disant que pour
réserver ces bouchons on allait mettre
en place un dispositif expérimental avec
des barrières amovibles qui
utiliseraient la bande d'arrêt d'urgence
ça a été mis en place après
naturellement vous l'imaginez toutes les
concertations possibles et imaginables
avec les services de secours avec les
directions de l'équipement et ainsi de
suite ça a bien fonctionné manque de
chance d'abord un accident donc pendant
des mois et des mois on savait pas
comment réparer puis quand ça a été
réparé comme par hasard d'ailleurs
quelques mois en quelques semaines après
une question posée au gouvernement
réparation vol de câble de cuivre et
depuis deux ans cette route est fermée
cette voie est fermée j'avais donc
suggéré bêtement que l'on utilise des
panneaux lumineux qui indiquent depuis
les gens voient auxiliaire fermé qu'on
les utilise pour pouvoir mettre
la voix est ouverte ou la voie est
fermée et qu'on puisse réguler en amont
et en aval cette circulation sur
l'autoroute A4 à 86 jamais de réponse
sur cette question de bon sens jamais de
concertation avec les élus encore moins
avec les riverains et avec les
usagers récemment le préfet du
Val-de-Marne que j'ai interrogé me
répond que les services de secours et de
sécurité seraient opposé à cette
réouverture et souhaiterait
l'usage de la cette voie alors je dis
oui oui au ministre des Transports
réouvrons au moins la voie auxiliaire
pour les services de secours mais pour
l'instant même ne peuvent pas l'utiliser
puisque les barrières sont toujours sont
toujours mises en travers de la voix
auxiliaire alors montant de redire par
les services de l'État qu'on ne peut pas
l'utiliser parce que les de sécurité
veulent utiliser cette voix et qu'on la
laisse toujours dans l'état me paraît
quand même étonnant la mission première
de la bande d'arrêt d'urgence et bien de
servir d'urgence et bien ni les ni les
services de police les pompiers ni les
ambulances ne peuvent l'emprunter et un
véhicule en panne ne peut pas non plus
stationner donc j'aimerais bien madame
le ministre si on vous a donné les
informations que vous me disiez qu'elle
est clairement la position du nouveau
gouvernement pour mettre fin à cette
situation complètement aberrante et au
blocage non seulement de la voix mais au
blocage aussi de certains dans ces
directions de la sécurité routière ou de
la dérive qui semble ne rien vouloir
bouger au choses merci Madame merci ma
chère collègues madame la ministre merci
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs madame la
sénatrice
vous avez voulu appeler l'attention du
ministre délégué en charge des
transports de la mer et de la pêche sur
la fermeture à la circulation des voies
auxiliaires sur bande d'arrêt d'urgence
sur le tronc A4 à 86 à l'est de Paris et
je pense que vous serez satisfait de la
réponse
mise en service en septembre 2005 le
dispositif de voie auxiliaire consistait
à exploiter dans les périodes de fort
trafic une voie supplémentaire il s'agit
d'une exploitation dynamique de la bande
d'arrêt d'urgence à l'aide d'équipements
actifs panneaux à messages variable
signaux d'affectation de voie caméra et
barrière mobile les premières années de
fonctionnement du dispositif ont montré
son intérêt indéniable pour les usagers
du tronc commun en permettant
d'améliorer sensiblement la fluidité du
trafic sur l'axe pour un coût de l'ordre
de 20 millions d'euros nettement
inférieur à celui de travaux
d'infrastructures d'efficacité
équivalente
malheureusement cette phase de
fonctionnement également mise en lumière
la vulnérabilité du dispositif aux
accidents de la circulation et aux actes
devantalisme la dégradation due à ces
événements répétitifs a conduit à
l'arrêt du dispositif en 2009 des
tentatives de réparation menées en 2010
et en 2011 que vous avez rappelé
vous-même ce sont heurté de nouveau à
des actes de malveillance dès lors une
refonte en profondeur du fonctionnement
du dispositif a été entamé reposant à la
fois sur la protection renforcée des
dispositifs de télécommunications contre
le vandalisme et l'adaptation du
dispositif de signalisation en
s'appuyant sur l'expérience acquise
depuis le début de l'année 2012 des
travaux ont donc été réalisés pour
améliorer ce dispositif en vue de sa
réouverture ainsi je puis vous annoncer
que la glissière mobile sera remise en
service cette semaine dans le sens de la
circulation vers Paris et dans quelques
mois dans l'autre sens en fonction de
l'achèvement des travaux du tunnel de
Nogent donc l'arrêt ouverture c'est pour
maintenant plus globalement cette
opération me paraît emblématique de la
politique des transports du gouvernement
qui donne la priorité au transport au
quotidien il s'agit d'une opération d'un
coût raisonnable et pouvant être mise en
place rapidement qui soulagera des
milliers d'usagers
merci Madame la Ministre madame procacia
hormis merci merci à vous d'avoir
apporté cette réponse merci au ministre
des Transports qui a enfin obtenu
quelque chose et je peux vous dire que
je pense que dès demain vous ferez la
une des journaux locaux qui pourront
dire que cette voie est enfin réouverte
et que toutes les communes non seulement
riveraines mais jusqu'à Rungis vont
pouvoir enfin sentir une amélioration
j'espère que tous les travaux qui se
sont apportés cette fois-ci avec la
signalisation avec la surveillance des
vols ne nous conduiront pas dans trois
quatre mois à une nouvelle fermeture
mais en tout cas merci de cette de cette
très bonne réponse